near latha tap the crawling chaos I am
the last I will tell the audience
I do not recall distinctly when it began
but it was months ago the general
tension was horrible to a season of
political and social upheaval was added
a strange and brute in apprehension of
hideous physical danger a danger
widespread and all embracing such a
dangerous may only be imagined in the
most terrible fantasies UM's of night I
recall that people went about with pale
and worried faces and whispered warnings
and prophecies which no one dared to
consciously repeat or acknowledge to
himself that he had heard a sense of
monstrous guilt was upon the land and
out of the abyss between the stars swept
chill currents that made men shiver in
the dark and lonely places there was a
demon a a corporation in the sequence of
the seasons the autumn heat lingered
fearsomely and everyone felt that the
world and perhaps the universe had
passed from the control of known gods or
forces to that of gods or forces which
were unknown and it was then that Neil
Arthur Tet came out of Egypt who he was
no one could tell but he was of old
native blood and looked like a pharaoh
the fella he knelt when they saw him yet
could not say why he said he had risen
out of the blackness of twenty-seven
centuries and that he had heard messages
from places not on this planet into the
lands of civilizations came near latha
Thep swarthy slender and sinister always
buying strange instruments of glass and
metal and combining them into
instruments yet stranger he spoke much
of Sciences of electricity and
psychology and gave exhibitions of power
that sent he spectators away speechless
yet which swelled his fame to exceeding
magnitude
men advise one another to see Niall
Arthur tap and shuddered and where Niall
Arthur tip went rest vanished for the
small hours were rent with screams of
nightmare never before had screams of
nightmare been such a public problem now
the wise men almost wish they could
forbid sleep in the small hours that the
shrieks of cities might less horribly
disturb the pale pitying moon as if
glimmered on green waters gliding under
bridges an old steeples crumbling
against the sickly sky I remember when
Neil Arthur Tech came to my city the
great the old the terrible city of
unnumbered crimes my friend had told me
of him and of the impelling fascination
and allurement of his revelations and I
burned over eagerness to explore his
uttermost mysteries my friend said they
were horrible and impressive beyond my
most fevered imaginings that ball was
thrown on a screen in the darkened room
prophesized things none but nila that
have dared to prophesy and that in a
sputter of his sparks there was taken
from men which had never been taken yet
which shewed only in the eyes and I
heard it hinted abroad that those who
knew Neil Arthur tip looked on sights
which others saw not and was in the hot
autumn that I went through the night of
the Restless crowds to see niall Arthur
tap through a stifling night and up the
endless stairs into the choking room and
shadowed on a screen I saw hooded forms
emits ruins and yellow evil faces
peering from behind fallen monuments and
I saw the wound batten against blackness
against the waves of destruction from
ultimate space whirling churning
struggling around the dimming cooling
Sun then the sparks played amazingly
around the heads of spectators and hair
stood up on end or shadows more
grotesque than I can tell came out and
squatted on their heads and when I who
was colder and more scientific than the
rest
mumbled a trembling protest about
imposture and
static electricity near la that have
drave us all out down the dizzy stairs
into the damp hot deserted midnight
streets and i screamed aloud that i was
not afraid that i could never be afraid
and other screamed with me for solace
and we swear to one another that the
city was exactly the same and still
alive and when the electric lights began
to fade we cursed the company over and
over again and laughed at the queer
faces we made I believe we felt
something coming down from the greenish
moon for when we began to depend on its
light we drifted into curious
involuntary formations and seemed to
know our destinations though we dare not
think of them once we look to the
pavement and found blocks loose
displaced by grass with a scarce line of
rusted metal to shew where the tramways
had run and again we saw a tramcar lone
windowless dilapidated and almost on its
side when we gazed around the horizon we
could not find the third tower by the
river and noticed that the silhouette of
the second tower was ragged at the top
then we split up into narrow columns
each of which seemed to be drawn in a
different direction one disappeared into
the narrow alley to the left leaving
only the echo of a shocking moan another
fled down a weed-choked subway entrance
howling of a laughter that was mad my
own column was sucked towards the open
country and presently felt it sure that
was not of the hot autumn for as we
stalked out onto the dark Moor we beheld
around us the hellish moon glitter of
evil snows trackless inexplicable snow
swept asunder in one direction only were
lay a golf all the blacker for its
glittering walls the column seemed very
thin indeed as it plodded dreamily into
the Gulf I lingered behind for the black
rift in the green Litton's snow was
frightful and I had thought I had heard
the operations of a disquieting whale as
my companions vanished but my power to
linger was slight as if beckoned by
those who had gone before I half floated
between the Titanic snowed
quivering and afraid into the site nurse
vortex of the unimaginable screamingly
sentient dumbly delirious only the gods
that were can tell a sickened sensitive
shadow writhing in hands that are not
hands and whirled blindly past ghastly
Midnight's of rotting creation corpses
of dead worlds with sores that were
city's carnal winds that brushed the
pallid Stars and make them flicker low
beyond the worlds vague ghosts of
monstrous things half-seen columns of
unsanctified temples that rest on
nameless rocks beneath space and reach
up to dizzy vacuo
above the spheres of light and darkness
and through this revolting graveyard of
the universe the muffled maddening
beating of drums and thin monotonous
whine of blasphemous flutes from
inconceivable unlighted chambers beyond
time the detestable pounding and piping
were untied on slowly awkwardly and
absurdly the gigantic tenebrous ultimate
gods the blind voiceless
- gargoyles whose soul is near latha tap
you